[Laughter]
our viewers at home to knock the dogs
off the couch and find the comfy spot
because vladius here for what to watch
this is
it is our happy place thank you very
much for that tony good morning folks
here are a few stories we think you'll
be talking about today
the ntsb is expected to announce what
might have caused the helicopter crash a
year ago that killed nine people
including kobe bryant and his daughter
gianna investigators are expected to
focus on whether
requiring additional safety features
could have prevented the crash
one of those is known as the tawes that
stands for
terrain awareness and warning system
ryan's helicopter did not have it now
taws
gives a pilot a visual and audio alert
when the aircraft is coming dangerously
close to objects like buildings or
mountains here's the thing though pilot
we spoke to with
who worked for the same helicopter
company involved in the crash told us
that the system
might not have helped in this case that
is because taws can repeatedly be
triggered
when flying through urban areas and
rugged terrain which can
distract pilots and of course sometimes
lead them to turn down
the sign the preliminary function yeah
the preliminary findings were that there
was no sign of mechanical or engine
right right and you remember that day
they said the weather was bad and that
other foggy
was it was foggy and that other uh the
other
planes and helicopters didn't fly that
day they talked about traffic reporters
that didn't go
media reporters that didn't go there
were all sorts of questions the day of
the crash about why that
chopper took off anyway it's important
as a matter of safety to find out
exactly what happened
you know how it ends and it's just a
tragedy yeah every time you think about
it that is the bottom line
it is uh think about it all the time and
we just
passed the one-year anniversary which we
all talked about here um hopefully we'll
get the answers when that report
comes out we'll have a report on it of
course uh okay another really important
story not getting a lot of coverage
officials in oakland california's
chinatown
have created a special response unit
after a string of violent attacks
targeting asian americans
some of the assaults were caught on
video and let me warn you right now they
are disturbing
a man was seen last month pulling money
from a customer's hand at a store
before taking off another suspect
slammed a
71 year old grandmother to the ground
yanking her purse so hard that the strap
broke off
and here this one is really disturbing a
91 year old man
shoved so hard knocked to the ground oh
my gosh
a man identified as yaya muslim is in
police custody in connection with this
incident he was apprehended after actors
daniel day kim
and daniel wu shared this video online
offering a reward
leading to an arrest our wijajiang asked
white house press secretary jen saki
about the violent attacks
she says president biden will not stand
for it
i'm not aware that he's seen the videos
but he is concerned
attacks verbal attacks any attacks of
any form are unacceptable and we need to
work together
to address them according to a un report
there were more than
1800 racist incidents against asian
americans from march
to may of last year as you know
president biden signed an executive
order
to prevent asian americans from being
targeted
it's largely to direct the department of
justice to prosecute those crimes yeah
it's symbolic but it's it's significant
i mean and what's really significant if
you look at this number
nearly a third of asian americans report
being been the target of slurs
or jokes since the pandemic began